otro viaje al espacio pero un gran salto
para las mujeres de Arabia Saudita
riyana barnawy se convierte en la
primera mujer de ese país en viajar al
Cosmos investigadora biomédica cuenta
con casi una década de estudios sobre
células madres en Casos de cáncer de
mama tarea que continuará al menos
durante 10 días en la estación espacial
internacional
estoy muy feliz y honrada estar hoy aquí
representando al gobierno de Arabia
Saudita y a la comisión espacial Saudita
como la primera mujer astronauta que
ingresa a la estación espacial
internacional
nacida en un país donde las mujeres han
comenzado a obtener algunas libertades
sus resultados pusieron el foco de las
autoridades espaciales de su país sobre
ella laiana
es muy buena científica le ha ido muy
bien en su área de estudio y en
consecuencia fue seleccionada como una
de las astronautas que podrán cumplir
con los experimentos
los ciudadanos árabe celebran el suceso
no hay dudas de que nos hace felices el
pueblo Saudita se está desarrollando y
ha llegado a los niveles más altos
gracias a Dios hemos recibido muchos
premios entre ellos nuestra educación
aspiramos a que la juventud Saudita
llegue a ser la mejor y alcance niveles
internacionales y le deseamos suerte en
esta misión espacial Quiera Dios
también forma parte del primer grupo de
sauditas en visitar el laboratorio
espacial internacional estará acompañada
por un coterráneo Alí aracni quien
también forma parte de la misión ax2
antes que ellos El príncipe Sultán Bin
salman era el único Saudita que había
viajado al Cosmos lo hizo en 1985 a
bordo del transbordador espacial
Discovery